the Joe Rogan experience hey so you know
this is one reason people believe
conspiracy theories is because a lot of
them are true yeah not all of them but I
point to with you with the Epstein case
like you were one of the first people I
mean as a literally you're a
professional skeptic and you looked at
some of the evidence you leg up well you
know what this might be a conspiracy you
know and when I said when Michael
Shermer thinks it might be conspiracy
it's probably a goddamn conspiracy
there's been enough of them I'm still
not sure about that one because after I
posted something about the you know the
two cameras broke or whatever somebody
wrote me from that prison saying all
those cameras are always breaking like
it's a little convenient though that you
know he winds up strangling himself in a
way that Michael batten the the famous
autopsy doctor says is completely
inconsistent with hanging and much more
consistent with someone strangling you
include including the actual area where
he was hanging from supposedly like it's
consistent with someone strangling you
from behind not consistent with you
hanging by your own weight
yeah after Weinstein got is is Harvey
Weinstein got his conviction I thought
oh boy but they better have a real
suicide watch on this guy because yeah
he's he surely has a black book just as
big as Epstein's oh I'm sure well I
think with what he's got is probably
more incriminating to him though you
know I think what he's got is probably
hey I had sex with all these starlets
and turned them into big celebrities and
yes and I bet he probably doesn't want
that out especially at this stage of the
game nothing I don't think anything he's
God is gonna make him look good and I
think the thing with Epstein is he knew
way too much about too many powerful
people there's just so so many
connections that could be made with that
guy and that you know to this day people
are asking questions that people like
Bill Gates don't want to answer or
Prince Andrew or any of these people
they're like you know I don't want to
talk about this yeah and I didn't hear
the one about gates but Prince Andrew of
course apparently flew on the lolita
Express four years after he was
convicted okay Wow all right according
Dalene air or whatever the [ __ ] it was I
know I would I would ask Jamie to look
that up but I've got his computer right
now when your iPad find out if it's true
if Bill Gates flew in the lalita Express
because that's what I was reading today
there people were trying to ask Bill
Gates but it's so hard to know what's
true and what's not true today that's
the thing is there's so much data and so
I mean one of the things that's really
sad about the loss of respect for
mainstream journalism and mainstream
media is well if we can't can't count on
them then who's regulating the
independence who's regulating these
websites who's regulating these people
that are just you know so-called
independent journalists that are just
tweeting things and finding things
putting things up on their websites it's
it's so hard to tell who's telling the
truth and who's not who I was when I was
working on giving the devil is do I had
this was kind of a challenge to me
because I feel like there's so much fake
news there real affect news and and you
know and just bogus theories and
particularly in my areas of you know
quack medicine and cancer cures and now
coronavirus cures you know like Jim you
know the old televangelist Jim Baker was
selling those silver pills that you were
supposed to silver derivative pills that
were supposed to fight the corona virus
whatever you know so a lot of that stuff
is dangerous to have that out there but
as a civil libertarian I feel like well
but I'm a free speech fundamentalist I
really believe you know people short of
just lying about somebody or giving away
the nuclear codes or something like that
you know just let a thousand flowers
bloom and to see but you know what just
shined sunlight on all of them and see
which one's rise to the top because
they're supported by evidence there's a
risk to that that is to say you know
people will take bad information and
they'll go shoot up a pizzeria or
something like that or not now these you
know this conspiracy theory about 5g
related to the corona virus that is to
say the theory is that 5g is causing
people to feel ill to take Cal and that
the government made up the corporations
made up this story about the corona
virus as a distraction from 5g okay this
is nonsense that's so criminally stupid
you know do you know who Lil Duval is no
of course not he's a hilarious comedian
who also has a great Instagram page and
he puts
thing up today retweeted something says
if 140 184 countries have Corona and
only five countries have 5g towers why
the [ __ ] would you dummies why the [ __ ]
would you idiots think that 5g towers
are causing kovat 19 it's that's great
such a great thing and and so many
people like oh yeah oh wow
and I literally heard someone say well
maybe maybe the 5g causes the corona
virus and then they spread it to other
countries like oh god you don't even
understand viruses yes well part of the
process but you know that was accused
with 4G and 3G and you know cell phones
back in the late 90s and early 2000s
there was the scare about you know
holding the phone up to you and we all
started doing that and that this is
maybe causing brain tumors and yeah of
course you can you can find anecdotes
you know this guy spent a lot of time is
cell phone he got a brain tumor over
here on his left temporal lobe or
whatever
the problem is well what about the
hundreds of millions of people that hold
their cell phones up and they never got
brain cancer exactly and then there's
that the physical aspects of it the the
energy from the cell phone itself or
even these 5g towers is not strong
enough to break chemical bonds like DNA
to cause mutations in cells to then
become cancerous there's not a physical
mechanism a and B the counter examples
that you always have to what about the
countries that don't have 5g yeah what
about all the people that you use use
these things or stand or live near self
cell phone towers they didn't get cancer
and you know so you have to look at you
know all the different options and our
focus tends to be on the one cell so I
always use this heuristic and for my
class of teaching skepticism is a two by
two matrix where you have four cells so
I did this with this there's this
documentary film coming out about horror
films that are haunted are cursed
horror films that are cursed so like you
know the the witch which is the one
where the actors died in the helicopter
act so The Twilight Zone the moon and
you know The Exorcist and these are
films were bet you know bad thing things
happen to the actors that are in horror
films okay the problem with that is
you're only focusing on one cell that is
horror films that are cursed what then
there's horror films that are not cursed
nothing bad happened to the actors in
those and then there's non horror films
regular films which bad things happened
to the actors and then non horror films
that are not cursed right
someone we just focus on the one cell
it's easy to find examples that fit it
but something like The Shining which is
a super or scary film you know nothing
bad happened to the actors and or just
take some other film like The Godfather
whatever that's not a horror film and
nothing bad happen to the actors and so
on so when you look at all the different
options this is just a way to think
about any particular claim that then
there's really nothing left to explain
because you're just you're just plucking
out anecdotes we love incidences they
really really love coincidence they're
fun because they love to believe in
spiritual connections and they love to
believe in clairvoyance and they love to
believe in haunted things Jamie pulled
up the article it's actually in the Sun
says Bill Gates breaks silence on
Epstein admitting he made a mistake in
judgment by meeting with the Peto tycoon
it says so there's a little story story
about it who knows but he's he is quoted
in there yeah I don't know i i i i know
i mean there's i know some scientists
that yeah because he was he had a way of
attracting famous scientists because he
had a lot of money and he said look i
can fund your lab help help find your
lab to the tune of millions of dollars
you know it's hard to resist that and
then maybe you go down that road a
little bit and then you start hearing
these rumors about his personal life and
you're like well yeah but the money's
good for the lab and you know you know
some are down the line it becomes
obvious it was a bad thing and it but
it's too late you already went down that
road so that you know it's hard to judge
people after the fact and hindsight bias
you know we look back and go how could
anybody have ever had any association
with them it's like yeah but that's you
know we know we know stuff now that
maybe not everybody knew the extent of
it back years ago
[Applause]